what are some things that someone should
know before becoming a filmmaker he's
strong know what you want to say take
advice don't always take it and just go
make something great at least try to
every step of the way
write something honest every day and do
your best to put what you want to write
on screen you say be strong is that is
that meant to to resist criticism or or
can you expand on that
be strong you know you should always be
able to to take criticism as an artist I
think that's part of the job but I think
if you have an intent and a voice and
you want to say something about you know
you're telling a story you're telling a
story about characters and why people do
what they do so what I mean by be strong
I think that you stick to your
principles and the theory and the thesis
of your story and you hold on to that
because you have to hold on to that for
two years you have to write a film you
got to raise the money you got to shoot
the movie you got to edit the movie you
got to make sure this one idea this
conceptual is conceptualized from the
beginning to the end throughout the
entire process right and then there's
distribution which is its own least yeah
and that's a different side of
filmmaking the distribution it's a
totally different side but just from
advice to young filmmakers is just know
what you want to say and do your best to
hold on to that every day what about in
terms of being on set do you think you
almost have to be a politician or is it
better to be more behind the scenes
because there's also a downside with
being too much the nice guy because then
you know someone could take advantage of
you or they think oh why don't I take
this guy seriously he's super cool don't
worry I can just do this you know that's
kind of what I mean by be strong is um
you know filmmaking is about managing
egos managing people managing your story
managing your characters managing a lot
of things and all of these things are
happening at a rapid pace you have to
make decisions as a direct
have to make a hundred decisions in a
matter of a minute so yeah there's a lot
of politics that go involved you want to
make sure that your actors are getting
what they want because they understand
the role you want to make sure that your
DP knows what he's doing you want to
make sure that your script is still the
same you can't lose sight of a lot of
things they're playing place so you you
can't it's a difficult way to say you
can't just be a dictator running your
own set there is there is some way there
is there's a middle ground between you
know the relationship that a filmmaker
has with the people involved because at
the end of the day it's a collaboration
its collaboration of multiple artists
especially even when you come down to
sound design and score by the time you
finish a film you've got you know I
think 80 people hundred people working
on it you've got at least 12 incredible
hopefully ideally incredible artists
that are putting their voice into your
film so being a director is about kind
of curating all those voices and
maintaining your own through this
through the entire process
you